hey everyone diavolo here and welcome to
my jujutsu kaizen character showcase
in each video we will go over a
different character their abilities and
their history in the jujutsu kaizen
universe
so brace yourself as there are spoilers
that come later on in the video but do
not worry as i'll save them for towards
the end or give a warning when they come
up
if you're new around here be sure to
subscribe for similar content and if you
do enjoy the video feel free to head
butt that like button hope you
all enjoy my first character showcase
now let's get into it
[Music]
we are first going to start off with the
eccentric doll creator masamishi yaga
the principal
of tokyo metropolitan curse technical
college masamichi yaga is a very tall
man
47 years old with dark brown hair and a
goatee to match
he owns a large stash of sunglasses and
is usually seen in a long-sleeved black
jacket
over a colored white shirt we first see
masamichi yaga in episode 2 of the anime
when izadori and gojo
arrive at jujutsu tech he is extremely
stern and prides himself as an educator
due to his pass to suguru ghetto he
tends to dislike people who are not
certain
with their motivations or they may seem
faulty
masumichi yaga's abilities
[Music]
he has the ability to control puppets
through the use of a curse energy grid
he does this by putting his cursed
energy into a doll he then gives it life
and starts to control it this is through
the use of his innate ability
called cursed corpse he has three
different abilities
that have been seen so far in the series
these being kathy
sukamoto and panda kathy is a
medium-sized doll that has been powered
up by masamuchi's cursed energy this dog
barefaced doll can throw hands with the
best of people
possessing an extremely powerful punch
and being able to easily bounce off the
walls
he can become quite a formidable
opponent we see this happen in the
second episode when itadori meets
masamichi who is paved off that gojo was
eight minutes late
he ends up sending the kathy beer after
yuji because he thought that the
reasoning behind
why he wanted to become a jujutsu
sorcerer wasn't good enough
sukamoto is a somewhat friendly bear
with a training purpose behind its use
it wears a pair of boxing gloves and is
usually asleep
unless someone isn't producing a
constant flow of cursed energy if that
happens
the bear springs to life and lays into
the person whose cursed energy
isn't constant this beer was also shown
early on in the series with itadori
in the first few episodes where he is
training his cursed energy to become
more constant
yaga was the man to create panda who was
a
mutated cursed corpse doll created of
three different cursed cores and a panda
although i'd love to explain panda's
abilities he has more of his own
character than just a mere cursed corpse
i will definitely cover panda separately
in a different video
in the near future so keep an eye out
for that if you'd like to learn more
about the history and abilities of a big
cuddly panda
history of masamichi yaga
many years before the series begun
masumi yaga
at some unknown point became the
principal of tokyo tech college
by this time he had already created and
was training panda
during these days masamichi met with his
students gojo aguirre where he gave them
a mission from master tengan
these guys were tasked with escorting
the star plasma vessel to the tengan so
that he could complete his once every
500-year
curse ritual if you'd like to know more
about gojo's past arc
and the star plasma vessel and that
whole thing let me know in the comments
below
or like the video up and i'll get a
video done on it because
like damn everything this anime is super
in-depth and interesting from what i've
seen so far
and i'd love to you know cover more in
the future a year
after he gave the mission to gojo and
guido he found out that suguru gesso
was on as a taji and killed an
entire village
and his family during the cursed child
arc
masamichi meets with gojo and discussed
how they were going to locate ghetto
when suddenly he showed up at the
college looking for yuta
masamichi and a bunch of other sorcerers
went to confront him while confronting
gito he makes the announcement
of an all-out war between the two sides
of jujutsu sorcerers and the vengeful
curse spirits he then leaves
during the introduction ark masumichi
met with gojo and yuji for an interview
to see if yuji
would attend the school when yuji
introduces himself masumichi asks him
why he is here
yuji says that he is here to help people
because it was the last request from his
grandfather masamunchi doesn't like his
response and says that he is
disqualified
masamichi then has more of his cursed
corpse dolls
attack yuji and explains what it is and
that it will continue to attack
until yuji gives him an answer he likes
as yuji is continued to be attacked by
the doll and trying to give a reason
masamichi explains what a sorcerer does
and how most of them die
when yuji says that he will never regret
how he lives masumichi
accepts his answer and welcomes yuji to
the school a few days later
jojo pranks mason amici giving him the
wrong time completely on the time
he was meant to show up at the kyoto
college with their principal
making them two hours early for the
meeting just a quick note that you may
be spoiled on things if you are just an
anime only as this is the arc that the
anime series is currently going through
during the tokyo goodwill living are a
fierce competition
that pits the teams of tokyo and kyoto
students against each other
in a series of intense jujutsu battles
masamichi is with yoshinobu
when gojo reveals that sukuna's host
yuji
is still alive to the absolute surprise
of everyone
he then explained the rules of the event
along with gojo to everyone as well when
the events start
masamuchi is with the other teachers
watching the event
through the monitors when the intruders
invade the site masumichi heads over to
go find tengan
after the intruders were dealt with
misamichi and the other staff members
attended a meeting discussing how they
were going to conceal from the
higher-ups that one of the fingers had
been stolen during the raid by mojito
and his crew
for some crazy reason probably because
it's an anime they decided that it's a
good idea to go along with the
tournament still
even with everything that has happened
and that is the end of the arc
on the 31st of october 2018 during the
shibuya incident arc masamichi yagya
teamed up with shoko and helped her set
up a medical tent he stayed with shoko
and protected her throughout the battle
as she was the only one
there naturally capable of using reverse
cursed technique which is used to heal
others and herself at one point
throughout the fight after yuji's body
was taken over by sukuna sukuna noticed
that megami had been
injured and decided to take him to
massamuchi and shoko to get healed i
always find it super interesting
how sukuna takes this kind of liking to
megami like he goes out of his way to
make sure that he doesn't die
i really wonder what he hasn't planned
for megami and if it's got something to
do with his suggestion let me know in
the comments
if you've been you know thinking the
same way or like if you've got your own
kind of theory i'd love to know
uh but anyway because of how masamichi
was inciting his students
which is just complete and
because ghetto is confirmed to be
revived masamichi has been sentenced to
the death penalty sadly
and uh well that brings you know
everything that we know so far about
masamichi yaga his abilities and the
history of him so far in the series
so from here it's it's really hard to
say what's going to happen with the
teddy bear loving slick suit where in
principle
masamichi yaga he may really be put to
death who knows
a jijutsu kaizen is such an interesting
show with an amazing world characters
and story i've really enjoyed doing my
research on the man
finding out some facts like a stash of
glasses
or that his catchphrase is god damn or
even
that he placed 40th with 233 votes and
the first jujutsu kaizen character
popularity poll
if you've enjoyed the video and would
like to see more be sure to hit butt
their like button and comment down below
letting me know
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo hope you're all
having a lovely
morning day or night and i'll see you in
the next video special thanks to
ryan josh for leaving that lovely
comment in the last video thanks heaps
and bye
[Music]
be